>>Anna: Hi, everyone.
I am going to start with a question.
Who here has read a Nicholas Sparks novel
or seen a Nicholas Sparks movie and cried
their eyes out?
[laughter]
OK, good.
That was the human litmus test.
I just wanted to make sure that we're not
all a bunch of Androids here.
I'm Anna.
I'm on the Google Play team.
And we are so excited to be hosting Nicholas
Sparks here today for this at Authors event.
[applause]
So, Nicholas Sparks is the great living American
romance novelist.
He's written 16 novels and has sold over 80
million copies worldwide.
And what's more fascinating is how beautifully
these novels translate to the silver screen.
Everyone's heard of or seen movies such as
"The Notebook" or "A Walk to Remember" or
"Message in a Bottle."
And his latest is called "The Lucky One" and
it stars Zac Efron.
So, everyone, please join me in welcoming
Nicholas Sparks to Google.
[applause]
>>Nicholas Sparks: Thank you.
Thank you.
>>Anna: I was hoping we could start off by
hearing a little bit about "The Lucky One."
>>Nicholas Sparks: Sure.
"The Lucky One" is the, it's a story that
was really inspired by the place I live.
I live in New Bern, North Carolina.
It's a, we're literally surrounded by military
bases.
So, active military personnel are part and
parcel with way of life there.
So, if you're gonna write a story with characters
who are in their 20s or something, you really
have to consider this as being a potential
what they do for a living job, so to speak.
So, this is a story, because also, let's go
a little further, because they are part and
parcel with the town where I live, beginning
in 2003 when they began to be deployed overseas
to Iraq and Afghanistan, you would see them
both before they left and then when they came
back.
And every single one of them came back changed,
different.
Sometimes, it was, and the level of change
really depended upon the experiences they
went through.
And so, you knew that this was a very significant
event in their life that they were going through.
These were very significant events that profoundly
moved them.
So, I got it in my mind this picture of this
marine who finds a photograph, right?
He finds it in Iraq, buried in the sand.
He picks it up, and then, you have this image
that stays with you.
And you say, "OK.
He finds this photograph and then I know that
when he gets back, he's profoundly changed."
So, you begin to ask yourself, "Why?
What if?"
And you begin to spin a story in little ways.
And you go through thousands of different
ideas and potential things you can do, but
eventually, the decision was that he begins
to regard this photograph as his lucky charm,
this talisman, so to speak, that keeps him
alive.
So, he goes to deployment one, deployment
two, deployment three.
All of his friends end up dying.
Everyone in his squad, his battalion ends
up dying.
He's the only one left.
He's got PTSD to a certain extent.
He's got survivor's guilt.
And he's got this photograph.
And he feels like he's got to heal somehow,
but he doesn't know how.
He sets off in search of the person in this
photograph.
And little by--.
And then, of course, it's a Nicholas Sparks
film and it's a girl in the picture and they
fall in love.
[laughter]
And they have the kissing and the water rain
scene, shower.
After that, it becomes one of my movies.
But there you go.
[clapping]
>>Anna: I actually saw a screening of it yesterday
and it was phenomenal.
So, I recommend everyone go out and see it.
Something I've noticed in your movies and
novels is that printed materials are very
significant.
>>Nicholas Sparks: Yeah.
>>Anna: Such as like you talked about.
In "The Lucky One," you have an old photograph
or the message in a bottle or the missed letters
in the notebook.
And just in general, your novels have this
really anachronistic quality to them.
But nowadays, when we're looking for romance,
we go on OkCupid and we message a hundred
people and see who messages us back.
>>Nicholas Sparks: Right.
>>Anna: So, I'm wondering if you think that
love and romance can still exist in the age
of the internet.
And if so, how?
>>Nicholas Sparks: Of course.
It's very interesting.
When I write these novels, I do so with the
knowledge, the full knowledge, that technology
changes very rapidly.
There's no question about that.
And yet, if technology changes fastest, than
culture itself changes more slowly.
It takes a while for culture to change on
a society level.
And it takes a much, much longer time for
people themselves to change.
I mean, the emotions that people go through
have not changed very much at all.
It's funny, right?
I write "The Notebook," right?
If you've seen the movie.
How many people here are even like that, right?
They found it dreadfully romantic.
Hey, this was set in 1946.
You guys were born in what?
1990 or whatever.
[laughter]
I mean, this is your grandparents that we're
talking about here, or your great grandparents.
But it feels real.
Why does it feel real?
Because when you see that person you fall
in love with, it feels the same.
And it doesn't matter when that is, whether
it's 2012, whether it's 1946 or anything like
that.
So, people change slowly.
So, I write these novels with this.
So, can these romantic elements exist in today's
day and age?
Of course they can.
Why?
Because your emotions don't change.
I mean, look.
These go back, these don't go back hundreds
of years.
These go back a thousand years, two thousand
years.
You look at something like "Romeo and Juliet,"
which was written 500 years ago.
These two were passionate teenagers.
And they fall in love, but oh no.
Just like "The Notebook," their families don't
get along.
This stuff, this works at any time at any
age.
I put these other elements in whether it's
a letter or a photograph in there, I just
like them.
I just like them.
I think they add something to the novel itself.
But at the same time, I wrote "At First Sight"
and it was a very heavy messages coming in
on email and a mystery that was really a little
bit more dependent on modern technology.
So, it really goes to the story itself.
Not opposed.
Not against.
I'll use it when it's efficient.
But in the end, I'm just writing about these
unchanging human emotions, like love.
[laughter]
>>Anna: Thank you.
So, you yourself are clearly really tech-savvy.
You're very active across a variety of social
media channels, such as Google+.
And you have a lot of followers and fans.
I'm wondering how this has changed the way
you interact with your fan base or if you've
ever drawn any inspiration from any of your
social media channels.
>>Nicholas Sparks: As far as, yeah.
I am very active.
It is something that you have to do.
This is changing the world.
This technology is changing the way people
interact.
It certainly changes the way that someone
like me, as an author, interacts with a fan.
I still get a ton of fan mail.
I get, I don't know, 500 letters a week or
something like that.
But I get a lot of email.
I get a lot of messages on Google+.
I get a lot of people posting comments.
And you certainly have to be aware with them.
And to me, this is really a, it's an interesting
phenomena in that it is a way to interact
with fans, of course, and this is wonderful,
but to what end?
What is the real purpose of that?
And I think we're all trying to figure that
out.
I can certainly say that we're trying to stay
on the cutting edge as much as--.
We're not the cutting edge.
You guys are.
I understand this.
We're kind of riding on your cutting edge
and trying to figure out the best way to use
that to everyone's benefit, whether it would
be the fan.
What is the best way to benefit the fans for
this?
And what's the best way to benefit Google?
Or, what's the best way to benefit my own
business, whatever that means?
So, we're searching just like everyone else
is for the best way and the possibilities
to use that.
But as far as drawing inspiration from, let's
say, messages that are posted, this is a very
dangerous thing to do.
It's a litigious society.
People are really--.
I have a pretty standard rule.
And that is that I don't take story ideas
from others no matter where they come from.
So, I don't read unsolicited manuscripts.
I don't read, "Here's a story that you should
write," because you don't wanna write something
and then have someone come back and say, "Oh,
I wrote you this letter three years ago and
you stole this story from me."
I just don't wanna go down that road.
So, it's just easier to say no, right across
the top.
>>Anna: That makes sense.
We, at Google, are really proud of our engineering
culture.
And over 50 percent of Google employees are
engineers.
But sometimes, we're pretty nerdy.
And we're not exactly the most romantic crowd.
[laughter]
And I'm wondering if you have any advice for
those of us that want to do something romantic
for a significant other, or are just looking
for love in general.
>>Nicholas Sparks: Looking for love.
Yeah.
Oh, boy.
Romantic elements, I think, are, can really
be--.
There's a couple of things.
It really comes down to knowing who you're
with.
And you have to know them well enough to know
kind of what they want because if you ask
my wife, for instance, sometimes the most
romantic thing I can do is leave with the
children so she could be alone.
[laughter]
She thinks I am just the cat's meow for doing
something like this, right?
So, you have that.
So, it's knowing what the other really wants
I guess.
And then, as you can be nerds, but you still
gotta know some of these great cliches of
life if you're a guy.
One of the great pieces of knowledge you must
carry with you throughout your married life
is "happy wife, happy life."
[laughter]
This is very, very, very true.
And so, what does that mean?
It means hey, you might send flowers when
they don't expect it.
And if you're a nerd, you can use the Google
calendar and the alarm will go off on the
12th of every month.
And then, you don't even have to think about
it, but your significant other thinks you
are the cat's meow.
So, you just have to maybe think about it
once a year--time to write the letter, time
to buy the candy, time to buy a flower.
Use your technology and who you are to your
advantage.
And they'll think you're just, they'll think
you're the bomb.
You're like Noah Calhoun.
You're, that's it.
And then, of course, you do need to learn
to kiss romantically in the rain.
It is a requirement for the ultimate romantic
element.
[laughter]
Or, for instance, in "The Lucky One," you
can use an outdoor shower.
But it is a skill that I would highly encourage
everyone to master.
>>Anna: What about as a woman?
Are there certain things that we can do to
be romantic for our men?
>>Nicholas Sparks: It's, it comes down to
the relationship itself.
And to me, when I create female characters,
it's very funny because I generally create
all these female characters--whichever novel
you read or whichever film you see--these
females I create have certain characteristics.
And they're the ones I find most attractive
and what are they?
Intelligence, passion, sense of humor.
But more than anything, it is that I don't
want a wishy-washy woman.
I don't want her to be defined by me.
I want her to be her what ever that means.
For my wife, who doesn't work, she loves children.
She was born to be a mom and she's exceptionally
good at this.
But if there's a guy that defines her in her
life, I guess I'm number four, right?
'Cause I have three sons.
I like this, though.
I like this.
I want them to be who they are.
So, I guess the main point I'm trying to make
from that is be who you are.
Don't be defined solely by your relationship.
Be who you are, whether it's work or family
or other friendships.
Be who you are and then find the guy who appreciates
this quality in you.
And then, of course, if he's doing nice things
for you, you do nice things for him.
We can get back to the kissing in the rain
thing.
But, there we go.
>>Anna: Do you have an example of something
really romantic you've done for your wife?
>>Nicholas Sparks: Oh, my goodness.
Yeah.
I've got all sorts of things.
Sure.
[laughter]
I mean, you try to do nice things.
I wrote her a love letter on Valentine's Day.
How's that?
And it was a really good letter.
[laughter]
I scribbled this thing out in like, ten minutes.
No.
I wrote it on my computer first.
I edited it.
Got every word right.
And then, I hand wrote it out.
See, that's the way you do it, right?
It's using technology with the delete key
to your advantage and then going back to the
old days.
>>Anna: Wow.
It's pretty romantic.
I read on your website that you worked a variety
of odd jobs before your novel got picked up
by an agent.
And it all seemed pretty lucky.
I'm wondering if your life, if your life would
have been different had there been the existence
of eBooks or the self-publishing revolution,
when you first started writing?
>>Nicholas Sparks: eBook and self-publishing,
that is something certainly that we're confronting
today and it is a change.
I do believe that my own personal belief is
that there is something intrinsic in human
nature that makes people desire to hear a
good story.
And whatever medium that comes out in, whether
it's a play or a film or a story, an oral
story, just sitting around the camp fire,
someone telling a story or reading a story,
I just think there's something intrinsic in
human nature that desires such a thing.
If only, maybe it's because it gives us an
opportunity to escape our lives for a short
period of time, we can live within other characters.
We can have super powers, like Spiderman or
whatever, if that's your cup of tea.
It gives us this opportunity to really escape
into another world for a short period of time.
So, I don't know that any of the modern technology
changes--again, it goes back to that human
nature, this slow-changing emotion.
I don't know that it's really going to change
the mediums in which it's delivered will change.
And I certainly think that, as an author,
you have to be aware of these things.
And you have to be aware of them and you have
to be ready for the changes and that's why
I'm here.
Hey, we're trying.
Look, I wrote my first novel on a typewriter.
For you young people, that's an ancient mechanical
device they used to actually roll paper in
and write.
And so now, it's computers.
Now, it's this.
A few years ago, there was no Google.
And so, here I am.
Now, I'm heavily Googled.
So, you have to be aware of all these changes.
And, but in the end, from my perspective,
I just have to tell a good story and then
be aware and take advantage of the best medium
to deliver that story.
And it changes.
And look, we try our best to keep up with
these things.
And we're here, really.
Look, I came in with like 15 or I don't know,
ten people.
These people who came with me today, they're
not here for me.
They hear me all the time.
They're here for you guys.
They're like, "I wanna go to Google."
[laughter]
"Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You.
Yeah, yeah, yeah."
And I know that's the chink, but they're here
to learn how we can do things better.
I swear, I mean, if I wasn't at Google, none
of them would be here.
[laughter]
They're laughing.
Yes.
This is true.
I understand this because they are here to
learn how we can do this better because we're
doing our best to stay on top of these changing
trends.
But in the end, my job is still just to tell
the best story that I can.
And then, have it delivered to the most people
that I can.
>>Anna: Thank you.
So, we're gonna take a few audience questions
now.
So, audience members, if you have anything
to ask Mr. Sparks, there's a microphone up
there.
And you can line up there.
And also, I'll be reading a few questions
that your fans posted on your Google+ page.
>>Nicholas Sparks: Great.
>>Anna: So, Jessica Nueng Faung asks, "Because
your work is so prevalent in the media world,
do you feel like you are shaping the way we
view love?
Do you think your view on love matches that
of the books you write, or is it merely a
fantasy?"
>>Nicholas Sparks: I don't know that I'm shaping
love at all because I think that when I fell
in love with my wife, it's the same way any
of you who fall in love felt when you fell
in love.
Again, it goes through these slow changing
things.
So, I don't think I'm shaping it.
I'm perhaps reflecting it because what I do
try to do is to--.
It's less--.
I don't try to manipulate you into anything,
whether it's in the film or whether it's in
the novel.
I do my best to genuinely evoke the feeling.
"And what is the difference?" you might ask.
If you reach a point in the novel where he
finally says to she, he says, "I love you,"
the proper response from the reader is, "Well,
duh.
I knew that eight pages ago.
What took you so long?
Why did you hold it in?"
That's what you want.
But if they say "I love you," and you're like,
"Really?
Right now?
They just met."
That would be manipulation, whereas I really
try to genuinely evoke.
So, I don't think I'm reflecting it, nor do
I really think I'm making it into something
unrealistic, either.
I met my wife on a Monday on Spring Break
in Florida.
OK.
And if you have any ideas in your head about
what Spring Break and Florida is like and
you've never been there, it's exactly what
you're imagining it to be.
[laughter]
Met her on Monday.
Told her we'd get married on Tuesday.
Now we've been married 23 years.
We've had five children.
Here we are.
She, oh, by the way.
She laughed at me at this moment.
She thought it was a pick-up line or something.
But it is what it is.
So, I do think that these, that certainly
long-lasting love is real.
I think that when you fall in love, the emotions
you see on screen or in the novel, I think
they're pretty much what all of you have experienced
or will experience.
>>Female #1: So, Nicholas.
My name is Winnie.
>>Nicholas Sparks: Hello, Winnie.
>>Female #1: How did you feel when you watched
the movie, "The Notebook?"
>>Nicholas Sparks: Oh.
How did I feel?
It's interesting.
The first time you do it, the first time was
"Message in a Bottle."
My point is, it changes.
The first time you do it, they take you up
to the Warner Brothers set.
They bring you into this big theater on the
set and you're the only one in there.
And you turn around and say, "Hey, yeah.
Go ahead and start the movie now."
And you sit there and your eyes are all boggled.
And the whole thing is so absolutely surreal,
you barely remember the movie.
You're like, "I picked that name, Garrett
Blake.
I know where Moorehead City is."
It's all these things that were from your
novel.
You're like, "Wow.
Wow."
You're like this little kid.
Now, you're to the point where you walk out
and you're like, "Well, I think the chemistry
was very strong, but we really need to work
on this musical score in the third act."
[laughter]
"Some of the editorial drifts.
Did you notice how the clouds were there in
that one scene and then they were gone the
next?
We're really gonna have to talk to the editor
about that."
So, that's where we are now because we've
done it so many times.
So, you're asking right about the middle.
And it was right in the middle.
You're not struck by the surrealism, but you're
not in tune to all of the nuances of film.
So, you're probably most apt to sit back and
say, "Well, I thought they did a really nice
job."
I mean, that's it.
Did I expect, after seeing that film, that
it would like, air on cable a hundred times
a year ten years later or whatever, every
year?
No.
I mean, I thought it was good.
But they have these really, really corny lines
in there.
Like, "Say you're a bird."
"If you're a bird, I'm a bird."
People love this line because it was the way
it was delivered.
And this is meaningful to people.
And I understand that now.
But, for instance, if I'm sitting there in
the theater watching that the first time,
I don't get it at that time.
I don't.
OK?
>>Female #2: Actually, Winnie set up my question
pretty well.
It's pretty inescapable that your books turn
into movies.
So, I'm wondering when you write, do you start
thinking about it as a movie and do you set
up scenes in ways that would translate well
on screen nowadays?
>>Nicholas Sparks: That is a great question.
And it's difficult to answer.
The answer is yes and no.
Yes and no.
I am aware that there is a very high potential
that it'll be a film.
But there's no guarantee.
There's no guarantee.
And if there's no guarantee, in the end, I
have to write the best novel that I can.
So essentially what happens is it just makes
the bar that much higher that you have to
jump over because what you're trying to do
is to write a story that works on any number
of levels and you want it to be original and
interesting and yet feel like it can happen
to anyone.
But if you're dealing with a concept like
originality, the bar is higher now because
it just can't be original for a novel.
It's also gotta be original for film.
So, for instance, I could never write a novel
that resembled "Sweet Home Alabama."
I could never write a novel, a love story
set on the Titanic.
This sounds obvious, but see, these were never
novels.
They would be original as novels.
But I can't do them, because I have to be
aware that they might make this into a film
and you want some of these images to be real.
So, essentially what has happened is it raises
the bar for those things.
It makes it, your story has to be that much
better.
And so, it takes longer to conceive.
But once you conceive the novel and you say,
"OK.
It'll be original if it gets picked up for
film, it'll also be original there."
Then, the process reverts to what it always
was.
And that was you just try to write the best
novel that you can.
Again, because there's no guarantee.
How's that?
>>Anna: Great.
So, Cathy Ellias asks, "What was it like working
with the amazing, unbelievably hot, Zac Efron?"
[laughter]
>>Nicholas Sparks: Well.
I like Zac.
I mean, I wasn't, when you're involved in
a level where I am, you look for different
things.
What was I looking for when I worked with
Zac?
I really wanted someone who cared passionately
about the role.
And he was really willing to put the work
in necessary.
And I wanted someone who would work with the
director and just be the consummate professional
and really put in a strong performance.
So, you're looking for that on a professional
level.
And then, on a personal level, look.
I bring my little girls.
I have daughters.
I have five children.
But my daughters, they saw "High School Musical."
They wanted to see Zac Efron.
So they're like, "Daddy.
Can we go to the set?"
You're like, "Yes.
Let's go."
And so, you bring them.
So, what would you want if they're your daughters?
What would you want Zac to do?
Be nice to them.
That's really what you want.
You want them to bend down, say hi, talk to
them, take a picture with them.
Just be nice.
OK.
He was.
And he's really genuinely a--.
Zac doesn't--.
He's a really nice guy.
He doesn't have a mean bone in his body.
So, on a professional level, you get everything
you wanted.
And then, on a personal level, you get what
you expect or what you hope for.
So, for me, the hot part didn't really play
into it as much, I guess is what I'm trying
to say.
But these other things, it was great.
>>Anna: Unbelievably amazing.
>>Nicholas Sparks: OK.
Yeah.
Well, he was.
Actually, his performance was unbelievably
amazing.
When you see him, he does not look like young
Zac.
He looks like he's on his way to being a real
leading man in the future.
He plays a young man.
And he's 24.
And we wanted him because he's the same age
as the marines that live in my town.
If you're not an officer, you're 18 to 25.
So, he was perfect.
>>Anna: Thank you.
>>Female #3: I have a quick question for you.
Obviously, you've written quite a number of
books.
Which one is your favorite?
>>Nicholas Sparks: Ooh.
Which one is my favorite?
A couple ways to answer that.
I think the one that was my favorite was "Three
Weeks With My Brother."
That's a memoir.
And I liked that story.
It was a story about a trip that my brother
and I took around the world.
And this trip took three weeks, hence the
highly original title "Three Weeks With My
Brother."
And you what this is about though?
It tells a story of--.
You'll learn a little bit about me in all
this stuff.
But really, it's a story about brotherhood.
And it's about family because my brother and
I, we went, we lost, we had a very challenging
period for a while.
I lost my mother and my father and my younger
sister in a relatively short period of time,
so that the only ones left in our family were
my brother and I.
We were the only ones left.
But how do you get beyond the death of your
family?
How do you do that?
You gotta have someone there.
And for me, it was my brother.
So, it's a story about brotherhood, but it's
a story about the power of family.
It's a story about healing.
It'll make you laugh.
It'll make you cry.
And you learn a little bit about the world.
So, to me, that is the book I recommend.
Hey, you've never read me?
Try this one.
I can't you'll like exactly the novels that,
every novel.
Everyone has different opinions on novels
and what kind they like to read.
But this is a memoir of sorts.
And it's really a memoir that I think will
make you closer to your own family.
And that, I think, is, or hopefully will inspire
you to be as close to your family as you possibly
can be.
>>Anna: So, you may have just answered this
question, but Dustioni Pinkham asks, "If you
could live your life out as any one of the
characters from your book, which one would
you choose to be?"
>>Nicholas Sparks: I don't know.
That's a tough question.
[pause]
I could be any of the guys.
[laughter]
Do you know why?
Because when I create these female characters,
they're all the woman that I married in a
way.
That's why.
And I mean that.
Oh, that’s such a cheap answer.
[laughter]
I hear you.
I can hear the wheels spinning, engineers
and all.
Put some oil in the wheels.
They're squeaking.
No, really, that's true because when I create
these female characters, they're all a little
bit, they're like my wife.
They're intelligent, passionate, sense of
humor.
They're loyal.
They love deeply.
They've got all these great qualities.
And the guys, literally in all these novels,
have to prove themselves worthy of having
a girl like this.
I've done it over and over and it's what I
find most attractive.
So, it doesn't matter whether you're Landon
or whether you're Logan or whether you're
Noah or whether you're John.
In the end, do you know what you're getting?
You're getting the girl.
And she's a good girl.
So, there you go.
>>Anna: Thanks.
>>Female #4: "Three Weeks With My Brother"
was one of my favorite books.
And so, I was wondering if you were going
to write something different like that again
and if you enjoyed writing that.
>>Nicholas Sparks: Yeah.
That was "Three Weeks With My Brother."
I have been debating.
I have--it's in my contract--I can write another
non-fiction book.
And so, my choice--.
So, I'm debating it.
If I was to do it and go that route, I would
do something like, it's called "Ten Days With
My Son."
It would be a book about fatherhood.
Because my son and I, we had this, he was
a track runner and I was his coach.
It's a very interesting relationship if you
coach your son.
And especially if you are as immensely talented
as my son was.
My son holds the junior world record in track
and field.
He's very immensely talented.
And yet, he didn't much care about running.
And so, it was a very interesting relationship.
And he's such a nice young man.
And so, I would write something about that--the
lessons you learn in trying to be the best
father you can be.
And I'm not claiming I was.
I was just saying there's a lot of things
you learn on the way.
Parenting is hard.
Marriage is hard.
These relationships are challenging.
And all you can do is try to do your best.
>>Anna: So, September Grace asks, "What is
the number one piece of advice you would give
to an unknown writer?
I would love this chance because I admire
your ability.
I dream of writing for a living."
>>Nicholas Sparks: The number one piece of
advice you can have and I have given this
advice over and over and over.
And I don't know how many people ever follow
it.
I mean, that's the thing about advice.
They don't want advice.
They want it to be handed to them.
But really, if you wanna do anything well,
you have to learn from people who do it well.
This is just, this is the best way to do it.
So, you have to read a lot.
You have to read.
If you wanna be a writer, you have to read.
You have to read across a variety of genres.
If you wanna write like me, you can't only
read me because my ability to write like me
comes from the fact that I've read a lot of
suspense novels because some of my novels
have suspense in them.
I've read a lot of horror novels because some
of my novels can get scary.
I've read a lot of novels about just family
matters 'cause I deal with father/daughter
stories, or mother/son stories.
So, you have to read across a variety of things.
And then, you have to read with an eye toward
what authors do well and then how they do
it well.
Like, if you are reading a novel and you say
to yourself, "Wow, I really like this character."
Well, take a moment to figure out why, if
you wanna be a writer.
Why?
Why do I like this character?
Was it her voice or his voice?
How many pages did that take?
Was it primarily narrative or dialogue or
did something happen and it was some event
that she did that really made me like her?
How long did it take me for like her?
Did I like her ten pages ago or did it come
on suddenly?
Why did it come on suddenly?
Was there a build-up to this?
So, if you really read with an eye toward
learning what works and what doesn't work,
well, little by little, you'll accumulate
the knowledge you need to write these kinds
of scenes in novel.
If you learn how to make a great character
you like, well, now you know how to do it.
So, that's what you have to do.
You have to read with that and then, of course,
you have to start putting it down on paper.
>>Anna: So, who and what do you read?
>>Nicholas Sparks: I read everything.
I read about 120 books a year.
I read all the time.
It's probably 40 percent non-fiction.
And non-fiction is history, economics, and
biographies.
But if they're biographies, they're not celebrities
or politicians.
So, any other biography.
You have to be dead before I'll read about
you, essentially.
And as far as the other 60 percent, it's a
lot of commercial fiction.
That's what I write.
You can learn from this.
It's, I've read the classics.
I read if I'm going to a foreign country to
tour, I'll read something from one of their
well-known authors.
I'll read selected literary fiction.
Anything.
If it's good, I'll read it.
There you go.
And in the end, that's really what I want.
I want it to be good for what it's supposed
to be.
If it's gonna be literary fiction, I want
it to be good literary fiction or I don't
like it.
If it's a horror novel, well, you better scare
me or I don't like it.
>>Anna: Thank you.
All right.
I have one final question.
It's from Mary Smith.
"My question is, how do you get inside the
heads of women so well?
You often write from a woman's perspective
and it is always so accurate."
>>Nicholas Sparks: Yes.
You see, the secret is I'm from Venus.
[laughter]
I don't know.
I had a great mom.
I married well.
My agent is a female.
My editor is a female.
And in the end, I just try to create real
people.
And I think that if you're male or female,
when you're sad, it feels the same, but your
reaction to that might be a little bit different
because I don't know.
I don't know.
I just do.
Maybe it's just 'cause I really like women.
I like women.
I try to understand them.
But we'll see.
I just, you try and put in how they would
relate to what you do I guess.
>>Anna: All right.
Thank you so much for joining us today.
It was a pleasure.
>>Nicholas Sparks: Thanks.
Thank you.
[applause]